petite session pêche aliments il fait
très beau bord du canal du midi
nota tout de suite en avoir un petit peu
fier s'il ya des choses à trouver
voilà en deux sets pour un demi francs
1,2 mille francs ouais 1986 à la cadrer
la sais pas on verra bien
on va
[Musique]
là une cuillère
voilà
r si j'ai un plomb
non
encore un petit point c'est grave
c'est
c'est des trucs pour planter là pour
planter un nom il était tout neuf
promu sans compter les recherches
oui ça soit la vente d'un obus papiss
cissé mais qui n'a pas pété
on va voir faire des recherches en
revient dans la roue
et comment
autour des millions de on peut appeler
ça du coup c'était cartouches mais que
le haut après c'était battre cartouches
pas de cartouches mais du coup ce
qu'elles sont tirés semblerait pas pour
demain pas de cartouche qui auraient été
découpés
alors peut-être qu'ils auraient coupé
pour récupérer ce qui attend avant de
tirer pour récupérer la poudre
alors voilà donc au c'est fini pour la
pêche aujourd'hui on est encore sur le
sur le spot on a trouvé beaucoup
beaucoup de cartouches pour que la
partie basse donc c'est assez assez
bizarre puisque en plus il semblerait
qu'elle n'ait pas été tirés sans sont
pas taper donc la cdu c'est du calibre
12 mais je sais pas si vous avez une
idée de pourquoi il y aurait autant de
cartouches dorées étaient en fait des
coupes et non enlever toute la partie en
plastique pour les jetez donc puisque
c'est pour pas que sa flotte est ce que
c'est pour récupérer ce qui est à
l'intérieur sans s'en servir avec le
fusil de chasse
on a pas mal de questions et beaucoup
beaucoup de deux cartouches
voilà il fait assez froid lorsqu'on
arrive à remonter en compagnie de cantat
encore une fois d'une portion du canal
du midi qu'on n'a jamais faites
allez on attaque tout de suite
vos morceaux de bach à faire avec ça et
une veille
oui
manche de bêche bon état je prends ça en
garde du petit cadenas inite 45 encore
trouvé la clé
il
oh
oui comme un gros truc le coffre de
vénal a en direct
le coq ou de benalla
une
générateur en coop
bon ben j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle c'est
pas le coffre de bella
il ya des corps c'est une sorte de
générateurs du coup c'est pas le coffre
de benhaddad en colombie donc on va
l'ouvrir quand même un bon petit paquet
d'intérieur dégueulasse comment il a pu
se conclure autant de buzz incroyable
nous allons découvrir en direct
l'intérieur du coffre d'alexandre peine
la lie à
des câbles ont l'avancé c'est pas le
coffre de benalla du coup déçu et choqué
un peu de de cuivre récupéré mais bon vu
l'état dans lequel ces je pense que pour
ce qui est du récap des trouvailles donc
après cette petite session de pêche on à
la pièce de un demi francs 1986 mois ont
plutôt bon état même temps ça ça n'a pas
une grande valeur a cédé france et c'est
pas des anciens on à la perte de 6 et
aux banques est là et surtout la tête
d'obus donc assez assez massive assez
joli c'est une tête de but de 1914
donc on s'oriente plutôt vers une au but
allemande et ce serait du 77 mm donc
voilà on va essayer de vous de vous
glisser quelques photos de de ces obus
là on a une seule petite inscription
dessus si je la retrouve
c'est là rien 4 on s'est pas trop à quoi
ça correspond
moi en tout cas merci beaucoup d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à nous
suivre on a d'autres vidéos qu'on a
tourné depuis un moment qu'on va qu'on
va monter pour vous les présenter avec
une tentative de restauration d'un vélo
aussi
[Musique]